oh dude oh that's I watched mr. Olympia
this weekend Saturday night there are
nobody watch bills not in it he got it
right can you look at why Phil's not in
because he law he lost he last year last
year's a very kind of fun so yeah I
don't know why he's not it but hey
last year's winner accused of rape and
you tall shout-out to your parents house
oh boy she's a wreck
oof tall and why is he not Phil Heath
will not create the biggest unanswered
question heading to miss tonight I'll
get to the broadcast of it was whether
or not my okay initially no branding
that heats would be taking this year off
of competition and seventy a streak of
winning and limpia is broken by shawn
rhoden who is doing in trouble he's a
Nazi would take this year off ever news
broke that Roden would be unable to
compete the air fall that people can't
speculate okay keep going down this way
alright okay okay I'm thankful to
finally announce that I'm not competing
this year's Olympia throughout my career
defeated base where I will be sitting
this year out okay I haven't stopped
raining I've chosen bypass this year's
event so no definitive reason I just
wanted a break right I mean maybe I
don't know but yes some mother she went
down to would with the judging but dude
body Billings died in the United States
died so there's no there's no Miss
Olympia anymore because nobody cares no
one what's the big thick surly chick
right so but with this one yeah I
watched this one dude it was like the
stream quality was so low at 18,000
people watching it one thought it's just
body but why is that that's I guess I
enjoy it has my uncle pax is super into
it so I got into when I was younger kid
has it always did have a running dude
hey I'm one who's Jay Cutler Ronnie
Coleman when it's Phil Heath ty green
Arnold I think that might have been also
before people knew the level of steroids
because things though I just think
there's some there like it's a little
bit like there's no there's no
entertainment like it's no I don't know
don't have any static - static stuff
stars
very
it what were you gonna say rigged a
board the end about it man judging other
men well justice was done outside beauty
contest the strides in this pack God he
looks incredible yeah it's a it's a
beauty contest men I met yeah which is
whatever I mean the discipline it takes
become that Treadway I listen when
people go it's steroid okay take the
exact you could members are taken you're
never gonna get there yeah it's a
combination of comics when really hard
work Oh technique I mean getting your
body like that takes it's just constant
work I mean you know you've met you met
Phil great yeah smart dude oh yeah and
it's a science I know you can say
whatever you want about steroids it's a
science fits diet it's exercise again
lowering the roar of the gun the left
was there saying a lot about this guy
that Iranian wolf he won he got third
what about him he's the author there's
the winner up above right there
alright that's their show Jack but of
course yeah there was no Miss Olympia
this year
look at his quads small small legs those
knees keeps going down okay
check out the hem is strange getting
your body like that is nuts though look
at the legs there showed what's funny to
me is people think how about he's 48
he's fifth place he's forty nights
wheeler bro that's flex wheeler yeah
is that flexor that deck sir where it
that's flex wheeler hold on don't worry
he's still doing the damn thing wait for
thigh flex wheeler was in the Miss that
that's incredible at 4848 dude look at
how shred it is how about chocolate
bodies oh shut up
chuckle Abati's go-go pad I mean I've
never seen flex
look at the veins it's so weird his
chest looks smaller than it should be
though I got a problem how dare you he's
jacked
oh you're judging look at that strike we
finished fourth that's sick little
peepees though you know why because
they're so dehydrated and then remember
Donna I steer all the testosterone the
steroids you're nuts go our work here is
done thank you
pack up our bags and take it up top and
they disappear who is that that might be
flex wheeler nope
excuse me
you know your [ __ ] all right don't take
it easy man I don't know that guy looks
like his face I've been flex wheeler
chin flakes weird they come become the
the the hey I got your anavar huh
I got your anavar I know you want to
take it you take it I want to see
actually this is no not-not-not flex
wheeler what is his [ __ ] name they
call him the blade typing the blade
bodybuilder the blade dude not flex
wheeler
you said the blade the blade Dex the
blade wotty boy Dexter Jackson I said
what I say Dexter wheeler
it's Dexter Jackson bro 48 years old
doing the damn thing he won mr. peanut
not this year but yeah that's his face
yeah that's him bro look at what you say
about his chest [ __ ] guys got a chest
on yeah dude that guy's got a chest
remember we've got a [ __ ] on there
when I when I remember I was flexing and
and and Phil Heath goes well you can use
some incline bench I I did I started
I've never stopped doing in climbing yes
now this doesn't work for me just can't
put on muscle yeah but I'm gonna limp it
used to be such a bigger deal even the
the convention is being in Vegas now you
hear anything about it know that the
Orleans now it's got a Sabbath or a wee
performance that's a depressing and now
from the fighter in the kid stages right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]